Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Finding Dory director Andrew Stanton has said
there are about 30 to 40 minutes of scenes
that were deleted from the movie.
For example, the Tank Gang was originally
going to appear in the main part of the film
and there are also interesting scenes in the
trailers that ended up being cut.
So, in this video, I'm going to take a look
at some of the fascinating deleted scenes
and rejected concepts that didn't make it
into the final film.
Just before I start, I've got a second copy
of this really beautiful hardback book "The
Art of Finding Dory" to give away thanks to
my friends at Abrams & Chronicle.
It's packed with gorgeous concept art and
information about how the movie was made.
For a chance to win, it's very simple, just
subscribe and leave a comment about the deleted
scenes on this video.
And of course, there are spoilers ahead, so
if you want to avoid those, right here's where
you'll find my non-spoiler review of the movie!
When we see the adult Dory for the first time
in the movie, she's talking to herself while
asleep in her coral home.
Still asleep, she seems about to sleep swim
out of her home, but she bumps her head and
wakes up.
Well in the very first trailer for Finding
Dory, we see an alternate version of this
scene where Dory also says "don't cry mommy"
in her sleep and then Nemo wakes up to find
Dory has gone sleep swimming.
This scene which was cut from the final movie
was actually one of the first sequences of
the film that went into production and was
part of a much longer montage of Dory sleep
swimming which had been storyboarded.
In the storyboarded montage, after Marlin
pulls Dory off some coral that she's stuck
on, she swims off still asleep.
As Dory swims, she picks up a piece of kelp
which catches and tangles up all the other
fish around her as she swims through the neighbourhood.
In one version, the "fish police" are despatched
to try and stop her, with Dory eventually
ending up at the drop-off with all the neighbourhood
fish tangled up behind her.
Another version shows Marlin tying himself
and Nemo to Dory and getting dragged out of
their home when Dory starts sleep-swimming,
and then the kelp line connecting them gets
cut accidentally by a swordfish who happens
to swim by.
At first, the beginning to Finding Dory was
going to include all of Dory's backstory,
much like the way Marlin's backstory was told
at the start of Finding Nemo.
Although this technique worked well in Finding
Nemo to make us empathise with Marlin, after
test screenings of Finding Dory at Disney,
the filmmakers found that they were telling
too much of Dory's past at the start of the
film.
Director Andrew Stanton realised he needed
to let the audience experience Dory's backstory
as flashbacks little by little throughout
the film.
And the flashbacks were actually also more
like memory recalls for Dory, which helped
us as an audience experience her story with
her.
You might remember Dory's line from Finding
Nemo "I suffer from short-term memory loss.
It runs in my family.
At least, I think it does", which Dory repeats
again in this sequel.
Well, the filmmakers initially planned for
both of Dory's parents to also suffer from
short-term memory loss in Finding Dory.
In fact, Andrew Stanton and screenwriter Victoria
Strouse spent nearly two years developing
the story of Dory's parents with this condition,
however, they eventually abandoned it as they
found it was too frustrating to have all of
Dory's family talk to each other and then
keep forgetting what they'd said.
In the final film, Dory's memory about her
parents and home is triggered after she's
knocked out after getting caught by the undertow
while listening to a group of migrating rays
singing about going home as they pass by the
corral.
And there were also another couple of scenes
about Dory's memories that were deleted.
In the first, Dory and Marlin go to Nemo's
Parents' Day at his school to retell the tale
of Finding Nemo.
When they leave, Dory sees a seahorse family
hugging each other and she starts to feel
lonely and sad.
In a second deleted scene, Dory spots two
blue fish, while playing around the coral,
and chases after them.
After she loses them, she ends up scared and
alone until Marlin and Nemo find her.
The first trailer for Finding Dory also featured
another alternate scene about how Dory remembered
her family.
That showed Dory suddenly realising she'd
remembered something, then immediately getting
confused, and forgetting what she was talking
about.
The Tank Gang do make an appearance in Finding
Dory's post-credits scene, but they were originally
set to appear in a number of scenes in the
main part of the movie.
There was going to be a section where Marlin
and Nemo look for Dory in the shipping lanes
after getting separated from her.
That scene would also have shown them escaping
from a group of squid by hiding in a shipping
container where they run into the Tank Gang,
who are trapped in a water bottle that a ship
had thrown overboard.
After Marlin and Nemo help the Tank Gang out
of the shipping container, Jacques and Peach
sneak on to a passing tanker, take out the
guards, and then they figure out how to navigate
to the Marine Life Institute on the Californian
coast to find Dory.
And there was even an alternate version of
this deleted scene where the Tank Gang call
on a shoal of flying fish they're friends
with who help them get to California to find
Dory.
It's such a funny moment when we meet Hank
in the movie and he starts drinking out of
that coffee jug, but the animators also had
a version of Hank where it looks like he was
a bit of a hot sauce addict!
There's some very cool concept art of Hank
hiding himself in a hot sauce bottle in a
similar way to when he disguised himself as
a plant in his coffee jug in the final movie.
Hank also had what could have been a cool
scene cut around the moment where Hank and
Dory are in Destiny's pool trying to figure
out how to get to the Open Ocean exhibit.
Because they don't know the way, Hank jumps
out of the pool and uses a wet-floor caution
board to disguise himself as he retrieves
a map on the ground outside.
He then brings it back for Dory to read.
The comedy duo Destiny and Bailey were originally
going to have different and much bigger parts
in the movie.
According to Kaitlin Olson, who voices Destiny,
early on in the story's development, Destiny
and Bailey were going to be sisters who were
kind of enemies but who would come together
by the end of the movie.
Destiny was also going to be a much more neurotic
and hypochondriac character, who screenwriter
Victoria Strouse has described as "constantly
on the verge of panic [and] a tremendous joy
to write."
There were also going to be a lot more jokes
about Bailey's "obsession with his head size"
and Strouse has said she'd love to do a spin-off
movie with the pair.
Although we see Dory swimming with some dolphins
at the beginning of the movie, at one point
in the movie's development, there was actually
going to be a group of hard-of-hearing dolphins
at the Marine Life Institute.
The idea was that the dolphins were being
treated for their hearing injuries there after
having worked with underwater sea-mines.
So, would you like to have seen any of those
deleted scenes and concepts in the final movie?
Or is there anything else you'd like to have
seen in Finding Dory?
Do let me know what you think in the comments
below!
And don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment for your chance to win this gorgeous
hardback book, The Art of Finding Dory!
For bonus ways to enter the giveaway, check
out the Gleam link in the video description
below.
If you enjoyed this, you might also like my
guide to all the easter eggs and references
in Finding Dory or my video explaining the
amazing deleted scenes and concepts from Disney's
Zootopia.
And there's links to both videos, which are
in my Pixar and Disney playlists, below!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!